welcome to this video playing in your
list that North Korea now it yeah okay
that's not it's not from North Korea I
think they have probably like zero chess
players or close to it okay a green
fault yep let's go with Lucy one there
should be six is currently the the
fashionable way to do this well that's
been a recent game between voy a check
white a check and someone who was black
haha I don't know Navarro someone what
to shake no it was a mushy lagrave I'm
sorry mdl yeah what a shake got a pretty
good game but how did he do that was
something with FYI remember but it was
something with a form so Knight f3 is
probably the wrong way it to start
anyway let's not spend too much time on
recording that game which probably or
something with 92 and f4 but I really
have no clear memory
yep so now I'm going to take just wonder
with what exactly yeah maybe maybe this
way I wonder if this kind of situation
if F was an idea at I mean you probably
will play wiki aid on 97 and then F for
the tip from the sf6 and I will lose the
pawn back anyway hmm maybe but that
doesn't feel super clear okay so he's
attacking AP form interesting
and f voice prevent and so I'm just
going to take it and sorry I take it
protected protect it is the right word
ok is it ticking this if I go g3 he has
to give up the check on before yeah so
this and now I was thinking if I just
think I castle and profile form I really
have a very nice development advantage
II form now now I thought you form let's
let's go for that not think for too long
yes so do I go f4 or 92 let it with a
special g4 may be okay star do this
okay yeah Bishop g4 that such a move
that looked rather annoying so try to
get out of that pin even though i don't
think that um I'm not quickly and oozing
with Bishop f3 or something that that is
not happening kill maybe let's trade
this to them that's surprising that you
would take on you too I didn't expect
this year five then what be six maybe
group is seven or something like that
b6 I wanted to go Quincy to keeping the
pawn for the moment and threatening to
take on b6 Queen takes as root d7k know
probably this is okay for him at least
okay maybe male maybe more just got the
Jeep on
draw our turn okay hmm no gain draw I'm
just worse I mean why is he offering a
draw don't quite get it what is the
account telling me something we had to
know ratings are fairly consistent what
ab it's a bit strange up a bit strange
and why don't I get examined mode no
that's weird and I really don't know
what happen happens here just a second
now I get the exam and load I don't know
but weird usually I entered
automatically okay this weird line with
Bishop back you know and this may five
all looks totally normal yeah should
reform now if I am opening up in the
center Bishop g4 yak f4 Queenie 22 was
my choice this yeah interesting maybe
somewhere here for looks kind of normal
and this then be six I don't don't know
the engine wants to do this and since
white is somewhat better our cable
difficult stuff this is the computer
line look here Teague's and then f5
yeah that's very difficult stuff it
gives white a slight advantage whatever
that means in such a sharp position
Quincy to where I didn't really had this
on the map but and now we offer to draw
the engine is actually giving 0000 I
mean I wasn't a very worried but
continuing I've heard didn't make so
much sense this and what's the engine
giving this move check them it's nothing
special really it's probably really okay
my king is safe so I rather would have
played it if I was in black shoes trying
around a little bit looks a little bit
easier for black to play well thanks for
watching